commodity prices are hot right now and
prices are surging but the impact of
these price increases on our everyday
lives is a bit more tenuous than most
people realize when the price of things
like arabica beans rise you might assume
that's going to bump up what you pay for
a cup of coffee from your local barista
but the price of coffee at the coffee
shop actually has little to do with the
price of the underlying commodity some
commodity prices do drive the rate
consumers pay but for others the
correlation is pretty small i'm going to
highlight a few examples and i'll
explain what you should really be
watching to tell you the direction of
consumer prices
with some commodities when market prices
rise that's going to move prices at the
store lumber is a great example when
prices rise in the lumber market you see
it pretty immediately on the shelves
lowe's famously installed digital price
signs in its lumber aisles so the
company wouldn't have to constantly
change them during the day with lumber
what's traded is mostly purchased by
consumers rather than broken up and
financialized through contracts on
exchanges propane is another example
prices for home tanks and cylinders move
largely in line with commodity prices
the price of oil is pretty tied to
gasoline and diesel prices but other
factors like taxes and labor costs do
play a role but with typical everyday
products it takes time to convert the
commodity into the retail goods we buy
and manufacturers often lock in prices
months in advance that's true for
ingredients such as corn for tortilla
chips or wheat flour for bread or the
cotton that goes into clothing the price
you pay for a cup of coffee at starbucks
is really more about the paper board
that's used to make the cups those
prices have jumped recently and that's a
bigger reason for the higher prices
you're seeing at the coffee shop than
the coffee beans themselves and the
rising cost of wheat won't affect beer
prices right away much of that cost
comes from aluminum cans and the cost of
energy and shipping if you're trying to
get a grip on which commodities really
move the needle here are a few you
should watch
the first is corn corn is in just about
everything because it's the chief
ingredient in the high fructose corn
syrup that's in products ranging from
bread to barbecue sauce and mini juices
and sodas corn is also a major input for
ethanol which is used in gasoline so
higher corn prices often mean higher gas
prices you should also watch oil higher
gas and diesel prices make it more
expensive to transport products and to
refine things like plastics
last but certainly not least is copper
known on markets as dr copper it's long
been an indicator for the overall health
of the economy because it's used in just
about everything housing electrical
equipment even motors copper prices for
home builders exporters and
manufacturers are generally very tied to
the price on commodity markets so when
you see copper prices going up that's
generally a good sign that consumer
demand is rising and we're seeing a
strong economy
rising commodity prices are playing a
role in the high level of inflation
we're seeing but maybe not in the places
people normally think of if you're
watching the market for signs that your
favorite products are going to be
getting more expensive
make sure you're looking in the right
places if you enjoyed this video hit the
like button and subscribe to keep up
with my latest videos on markets and the
economy i'm reminded of college park's
own gunna who says my new condominium is
dressed i see vvss and baguettes imma
get these commas and invest
i'll see you next time